right now the secretary of energy
wrapping up a visit to vegas
her trip comes as governor sissel act
signs a new law boosting
investments in clean energy the i-team's
david charn spoke to both the secretary
and the governor today
he's here now with what this new plan
means for you and your energy bill
david yeah brian the ceo of envy energy
was also at today's event and says
renewable energies like solar hydro wind
he says they're actually cheaper than
traditional sources now today's energy
event comes as governor sislek signed
two new laws aimed at boosting clean
energy
the new laws create two transmission
lines called the green link across
nevada
allowing the state to become a so-called
energy hub
for the west energy secretary jennifer
granholm was here to tell the american
jobs plan
an infrastructure proposal that would do
much of what the state is doing
and do it on a federal level i asked the
secretary what kinds of new jobs the
white house is talking about with this
jobs plan
on transmission you're going to need
electricians to be able to put that up
you're going to need
construction workers you're going to
need if you if you end up burying the
wild
wires you're going to need people who
are able to move big equipment you're
going to need people who plan it you're
going to need solar installers you're
going to need people who maintain it
and remember nevada has that goal of
hitting 50 percent renewable energy by
the year 2030 just about
eight years away now in response to the
secretary's visit
the rnc pointed out record high gas
prices we're experiencing right now from
that colonial pipeline ransom attack and
traveling over the summer
a spokesman telling us in part quote the
only thing nevadans want to hear from
secretary granholm is an explanation
as to why this administration is failing
the silver state
now a recent poll found nearly 80
percent of nevada voters
favor the clean energy aspects of the
president's american jobs plan
coming up new here at six o'clock what
the secretary says about storing
nuclear waste here in nevada hot topic
bringing that new at six
for now i'm david charns eight news now
denise